they are has become quite prevalent
these days I mean we see mobile apps
telling you to point your phone at your
can of coke at a magazine or something
like that all these solutions are
basically using computer vision and your
phone camera all the really doing is
recognizing a picture so ideally a 2d
image but they can extrapolate from that
once they recognize the image they can
get its position in space and its
orientation and then just tie virtual
content to it right now the problem with
that is it looks pretty impressive but
they don't actually these systems
understand the environment around them
it doesn't know that this is a card it
doesn't know that I'm holding it in my
hand or anything like that so if I put
my hand in front of it if it can still
see part of the card or anything like
that it will keep drawing the content
above my hand the illusion is it very
easy to break with these things yes
because you know the frame of the deck
from what we've seen in computer
graphics before exactly yes and also
limits the kinds of things you can do if
all it really understands is okay I've
seen this thing I know my position in
space it quickly limits the the things
you can do with physics or moving about
you're tied to looking at that marker
and maybe moving a little bit off it
with optical flow as we discuss another
time thing is that there are already
solutions was trying to deal with this
for example there is the Google tango
project which what they did was
basically they looked at the Kinect and
says okay what does the connect - it has
a depth camera it reads the environment
around it well it was designed to reach
and look at humans and register what
they're doing but it turned out was
pretty good at 3d scanning stuff so all
right let's strap one of those two back
of the tablet and they came up with this
this is the original google tango
development device it has on the back of
it a laser sensor depth cameras and what
have you
I believe it's billed as the spatially
aware tablet so it has a very good
understanding of where it is its
orientation what it's looking at and the
motion so what this does is it creates a
point cloud in pretty much well real
time of the environment around it unlike
the previous layout that is where we
started reading that reaching the point
where with an understanding of the
environment and
the motion of the tablet we can start
tying virtual content to things we
couldn't before so I can put a mesh on
this floor and it will stay there or I
can put a piece of sound on the corner
of this cabinet and whenever I come
close I'll get 3d sound but this is now
an old device assembly with about three
four years old and it was only a
developer device there is actually the
first commercial device the Lenovo fab 2
pro and believe it is now looking like a
proper commercial device horrible case
notwithstanding and just like the
developer device it does have an array
of sensors over here so what can this do
let's have a look is probably my
favorite example although it's not very
exciting we have this plane that is
reading the environment pretty well and
telling me what play I'm looking at we
have the green node oh yeah so the green
little dot is basically the edge
detection and this plane over here is
aligning itself to the real world so in
this case the table there is a white
plane a surface basically that is
aligning itself to the real world I can
see that maybe edges lined up with the
table and in if you put it near the wall
opens and as we go over the floor suits
but it's turning around and lining
itself to any surface okay okay so
that's all fair and well but what does
it actually mean well it means that I
can go and understand the real world so
there we go
hey let's measure the size of the door
you're drawing yep line yeah I'm
basically using a measuring tape and
there we have it
so there are centimeter markings on this
you can see how with an understanding of
the space around it can actually start
measuring as well so we could go around
this room taking measurement and end up
with an architectural floor plan I mean
that is one of the use cases real estate
agents real estate yeah it has it
already they wishing them using it to
create basic flow plans and 3d models
that they'll just chuck on a website
with a better understanding of what is
what the environment you're in is
populated
with and how the cameras moving about
you can start doing slow more
interesting things such as populating
the environment around you with your own
virtual content or whatever you might
want to see so this is the Augmented
camera application and what is a normal
camera application but again with that
whole understanding of the environment
things we can start putting virtual
content inside it so in this case we can
put a cat where would you normally have
a cat let's see here oh oh there it is
and reflect on the floor there and there
we have a cat that is standing on the
floor playing on the floor with thing of
the devices and understanding of what a
floor is and I guess we can also use a
laser pointer or we cannot all of that
is that it should when it sees it oh
there we are it's definitely not acting
like in cat I know to be honest but put
down a fish so that's fine it's
recognize the floor and we have a cat
playing on the floor but maybe we can
get it up onto another surface that is
recognized like say the table and it
gets the difference between the floor
down there and the top of the table but
and it's jumped off the table with a
traditional AR application that was just
using a marker to do that it won't have
an understanding of that it would just
be drawing everything in relation to
that marker whether we had it on the
floor on the table it wouldn't matter
this now is we're actually having why
don't we say intelligent content in this
case populating our space our real space
the objects that we use everyday you can
see how this could end up being
something a bit more exciting in fact we
do have something to show for that one
of these so this is the microsoft
hololens same principle but strapped to
your face so as you can see here have
again it's pretty much a Kinect all
across the top over here all right this
is the proper heads-up display on say
some earlier endeavors like the Google
glass which is simply just the screen
off to the side which didn't cover your
normal vision with augmentin content but
this is I say the real deal
this is the what ah
I don't want to make that claim perhaps
it from a lot of the stuff I've tried
this is probably the one that gets it so
in fact we can show you a bit more about
that